why don't we try the 505 area code
caller from 505 introduce yourself and
you can jump right into your question um
hello David yes
hello my name is John I'm from New
Mexico I did have a Steven for you and
then I'll fall that followed that up
with a question all right um so I really
like your your critical thinking there
miniseries I often show your your
channel to people right and it's awesome
I start by showing them the critical
thinking miniseries because I think it
lends very well to your credibility and
it makes you seem very genuine and I
really appreciate that the critical
thinking miniseries thank you
and then my question is what your
thoughts are as far as the origin of
life on Earth
did you think like dude do you know what
a biogenesis is or that that's what what
I'm sorry you were in the middle of a
sentence there oh I'm sorry I was just
wondering if you knew what a biogenesis
was or what your thoughts are on that
my thoughts on the origins of life are
that life evolved on this earth from
simple organisms millions and millions
of years ago my views on this issue or
not in any way sort of unique or notable
I'm not a scientist I read a fair amount
of science and I not even really a good
person to ask about this but I guess if
the question is do I have sort of like a
religious brief in terms of the origin
story
I don't okay no not necessarily
religious what your religious
orientation was I just was wondering
like what your thoughts are on you know
your personal thoughts on where life
came from on earth that's really all I
was asking but ya know my personal and
professional thoughts fortunately can be
the same because I don't have to
moderate them on the program so I uh
right yeah that's that's my view awesome
man
well you know can Congrats on your show
and everything and I'm glad you guys are
getting a lot of more
Porter so you can you know like you've
been trying to get the rotating
vacations and I think that's awesome
thank you and uh you know keep up the
good work man all right thank you so
much really appreciate it and all right
yeah I mean that's that's my view on the
origin of life I feel like it's just a
boring answer but if you had like a
religious story yeah that would've been
a little bit more entertaining would
have been different for sure yeah